this
is what the future of the british
military will look like
small highly trained teams working
across the globe
and better connected with each other
than ever before
they'll be equipped with a range of
small drones that can link
back to android screens on their chests
the screens can plot the position of
enemy
and friendly forces and be viewed in
real time
by commanders back in the uk it's game
changing
we will retire some capabilities we
don't need we recognize that some of the
new technology
uh you know means that you need less
people to do certain jobs that's just
the nature of weapon systems and
and and technology there will also be
a new special operations force called
the rangers
they will train foreign militaries and
then go
with them to the fight
you see the army operating across africa
particularly east africa will see the
army with a much more persistent
presence
uh in latin and south america and even
stretching as far afield
to the indo-pacific rim but
there will be a cost on monday afternoon
we will find out
what the trade-off is it is rumored that
the army will
shrink to 70 000 soldiers and the number
of tanks
will also be cut
the mod has been given more money to
spend by the prime minister
but some of that will have to pay for an
increase in the nuclear stockpile
the arrival of new threats does not mean
the old ones have gone away
i really want to see our country protect
itself from the full range
full spectrum of threats i'm afraid that
does require us to
increase our defense spending to at
least three percent
if we want to defend our security and
our economic interests
the defense chiefs and politicians
believe that with the right technology
they can do more with less
warfare is changing and so must the
british armed forces
alice debunked sky news bovington camp
in dorset